[Music]
hello everyone I'm Wang Chan from
straight kids Wow oh yeah this is hot in
the building oh yeah it's Felix
yo Trekkies tambien should have been
three keys I am I am submitting the
BuzzFeed dungeon in the building the
boys and today we will be playing like a
little little game and how well do you
know the members of stray kid who does
the band think has the best style in the
group we are pension and hun rotten
hyun-jin engine hissing me I&H only be a
minute Billy why this no Hana Felix Oh
worse all islands of cruise they go over
the two months and go to three months
yeah 21 century fashion and I'm 22nd
century no come on
what's Chung jeans favorite TV show my
guy Cody big league yeah fine a straight
kid
oh yeah we have knowing Oh new journey
to win why you're strange thing on we've
ever oh my god miss city is Lena's
favorite City to perform you okay with
this
Bangkok the LA there's London there's
New York City this to me to see oh we
have a very good and ogp / FIFA Lee
legends Smash Bros splatoon
Tekken and he doesn't like three to what
she said computer game I might have said
League of Legends but because the video
game I choice yeah
thing is that worst gamer what favorite
alright the options are cake biggest
french fries alright chicken alright
yeah Oh what do you do my family it's
faint chain chain be feeling dungeon I
am the amazing I'm not any of course
major
there's I in so um I'm gonna have to
kiss ya mojo I got it yeah just a minute
I can't see me I just mean yeah hi
you're my best friend okay cuz he's my
roommate
oh all right next question
who said basics oh my god the oh my god
although you should say very kids yeah
oh come on you should take their own
life stasis it obvious yeah you would
Bank and choose to trade places with
Beyonce oh yeah why did it you know
how about Tom Horne Tribune say yes Lena
would choose his mom what ohad why you
choose me through this you're tall and
handsome thank you yeah why because
you're cute oh who doesn't like pencil
yeah who is foolish dream collaborations
affiliates Britney Spears basics
Drake show men this and I know the
answer you know I'm debating between
movie leaders and a sickness I just love
EDM music and Isis listen to his and I
just think his energy who thinks the
other members of straight kids would
describe him as noise absolutely but
this one's first-time difficult because
everyone's noisy
everything's me absolutely well then
everyone's noisy room everyone is just
so easy
yeah we're noisy there it is three
people in my head can do it
Hongbin Lina yeah
[Applause]
I'm noisy who says the triceps of this
best physical feature what tricep a real
big message what Lena's secret victim he
can twist his hand 360 degrees and he's
an exceptional ship know who make
mosquito sounds he can fall asleep boss
I think I know what this is yeah plus 3
100 ask me my Elvis a double-jointed so
what I can do is we start at 12 o'clock
and we can just go around like Oh secret
Alex which Korea would I in be pursuing
if he wouldn't a member of straight kid
on earth I know what can the glad to
teach up yeah yeah music could you say
up dude yeah oh yeah I in said he would
be starting to become a social worker or
kindergarten teacher Wow
how would Felix describe himself there's
ambitious there's clueless this friendly
funny playful and unique he loves
himself what you describe yourself I
think your voice is unique
yeah you uh worse than ever everyone
special everyone was born specially
anyway which actor would swimming choose
to play himself in a movie about his
life from the 100 Ryan Reynolds high
yeah
I think I read Oh lovely out of these
stray kids songs which song is the best
favourite by majority ah because I've
options a double knot Mero spread my
wings voices my side in 1900 this
quickly eliminate well it's definitely
not nineteen I'm pretty sure spread my
wings was probably chosen by still yes
voices was probably chosen by punchy
lifestyle is probably chosen by I you
don't know a mirror I think we now
choose the blood it's a song that gave
us our first music promotion first place
it's very special song to us we we went
places with newark yeah it's a very
special song yes
[Music]
ten all ten ten ten
I'm so bad I've got mine okay I'm 11
oh no Bank genius yokes ingenious Zhi
Bao I did not know I thought I got a lot
of wrong do I get anything Oh everyone's
a straight kid yeah we had so much fun
with Busbee today again yes so great and
also we have levanta and double knock
out in English young if you want to
check it out yeah
[Music]
[Music]